well i have some exciting news which is
this is all happening in real time
it is now 12 30 in the afternoon at
7 30 this morning i got my second
modernist shot my body is
uh now pulsating with uh
with the second modernist shot it is
coursing through my veins as i
speak and so this is kind of an
experiment in real time
uh the shot didn't hurt at all got my
first shot a month ago
today was the day sona you were kind
enough to come with me
yep you took it like a champ thank you
and they they told me
you might not feel well later today uh
or maybe tomorrow
that that's common but i'm deciding that
my mind is going to defeat this
it's mind over matter i'm just deciding
right now
that i have a very powerful mind and a
correspondingly weak body
so what i'm going to do is my mind is
going to say no
no i'm not getting anything nothing's
i'll have no side effects
i'm just not interested not gonna do you
feel anything yet like even a pain in
the arm
no no no i don't feel i mean there's a
slight it's just slight pain at the site
but i'm gonna will that away that's not
happening have you ever
done this mind over matter thing before
or is it no first time
oh okay this is the first time that's
not true that's not true i was once
i have a pretty strong will would you
say that's true sona you do
yeah and i uh when i'm there have been
times where i've been
sick and i had to perform and i just
decide i'm not sick
and then i have a pretty good time
performing and then i get even sicker
when i'm
when i'm off stage yeah that's true and
once uh
i was visiting uh my wife's family in
seattle this is like
eight years ago and a car filled with
her friends
backed over my left foot oh
my god and like her friends are big
adult males and they were in a car
and it backed over my left foot and i
felt a horrible pain
and looked down and my foot didn't look
right
and it was it turned crazy black and
blue
and my wife was like i think you broke
your foot and i just said
no no let's not talk about it
and then i never went and got it checked
out and uh
what happened my mind sona i just
decided i'm not going down that road
we're not going to the hospital i'm not
getting an x-ray
i'm not having them set the bone it's
not gonna happen
but there's no time for this [ __ ] is
what i said no but that's not how
science works like i know and my father
is a scientist
yeah i know it doesn't make any sense
but i remembered i
don't want this to have happened why did
you even get the vaccine then why not
just will power away kovid hey
well i think that's spreading an
irresponsible message okay
okay matt i'm sorry but i'm a believer
in vaccinations hey man i'm fully vexed
look
that's you've just raised a really good
question why didn't i just will myself
not to get coveted
yeah uh well that that you just
completely took apart my whole riff
i'm sorry no no that was that was sick
you know what that was that was
strategic i had a whole
cocky riff going and then uh now you're
like yeah you're right
i'm probably now i'm going to get really
sick really big side effects
from the uh second is your foot
permanently damaged
no there's no damage to my foot because
the accident didn't happen
that's how mind over matter works no it
didn't it didn't happen
you know when wiley coyote is chasing
the roadrunner and the roadrunner stops
and wiley coyote keeps running off the
cliff and then he stands there for a
long time
when does he fall when he looks down
when he looks down
yeah he's a great role model i see where
this is going yes he is a great role
model because he
is i mean first of all people say oh
poor coyote i see a guy who's
joyous uh i love the coyote because
me too he is always knows what his
purpose is always
think of all the calories that the that
the coyote is burning
chasing yeah he's yoked the roadrunner
yeah no that's not my
my point isn't that he's yoked my point
is that it's so
calorie inefficient to chase the
roadrunner
but that's one of those things that i
you know i uh
i don't understand i i i just
fundamentally don't understand as a kid
that bothered me
yeah i get it where's he getting the
money